hey what's up beautiful people welcome
to another episode of get close I'm your
co-host Geo and I'm Bart and I've missed
this so much
you have yeah I feel like I mean I think
I've say this every other podcast where
I'm like this is really the only time
you and I really have to sit there and
dissect a topic regardless of what we're
talking about because like
um anytime you try to do that in real
life we're either too exhausted because
now our me time is night time and that's
after we've done business we've done
parent we've done like everything else
that like when it's our our time we
probably just want to veg the [ __ ] out
and just be in each other's Essence and
we're just not even really talking
because we're just like
surprisingly this podcast is like the
first like down time we've had
right in the last like month or two we
have a lot of catching up to do guys but
it's been like
and then like life has never been this
crazy for me yeah even setting up for
this podcast it was like all these last
minute things and then
finally yeah we're here
but even not a hundred percent here
right because taika is at school I mean
is that home for a reason and so we have
to keep one of our ears open to make
sure yeah he's on my he's on my phone
right now so yeah um as you guys can see
from the title of this video
um it's been really rough one of the
roughest I should say
um but when we say this is your roughest
time like in your whole life or just
recently
um I mean like gut feeling wise it's one
of the roughest months I've ever had in
my entire life
so long I'm like [ __ ] are you serious
but I was like [ __ ] shut up cause you've
had
a [ __ ] I'm sorry yeah your life's been
pretty [ __ ] up I think it prepared me
for it
but wait huh what is going on so it
prepared you to handle the [ __ ] that
we're experiencing now yeah
what happened why'd you give me those
eyeballs out of the socket ice did I
yeah I was like it almost looked like I
was gonna like
you know that there's people that can do
that it freaks you and I was like I was
I thought I was like oh [ __ ] this do you
have a hidden talent that I didn't know
about
I am
um
I I can't
imagine it well okay maybe we should
explain it okay so I just feel like I'm
just I have like this knot that I'm
trying to work around why you gotta work
around it for because I'm just gonna
jump right into it and it seemed like
you were setting up the way you set it
up no I mean uh for me I just want to
like I know we've been pretty absent on
the podcast too so as much as we missed
this I think there's people that just
miss us and us all being our own little
Community yeah so I do want to catch
people up on everything that has been
going on on why there's this big absence
and on why we have a complete new studio
change
um obviously we moved as people know
that's part of it but there's also other
parts of it so I would say the um
Where Do We Begin The Hectic Hysteria
I think started for me the last week of
September
the last why was that what was happening
in the last week of September so up
until then
um all we know is that uh we sold our
house we made a decent amount of money
on it we're really happy about that
can't wait to share the strategy that
God is there and if you guys watched
there's like a whole video about how
like we made a million bucks so we're
really happy everything seems on the up
and up financially right
um we do know slightly on the on the
back burner um taika did get like two
seizures since then like one at school
one in LA
and so that is something that is kind of
like simmering in the background you
know someone forgot to turn off the
stove but it's not hot it's cool you
know so it's kind of like that
um the last week of September was when
you know as you guys been following the
Vlogs we've been staying in our
apartment right the the temporary
apartment yeah just I think when we
signed up for it I booked it for three
months but it was only supposed to be
for two it was supposed to be based on
our schedule because our schedule was
um we closed on the last week because
this house was currently being built yes
so they closed escrow and then this
house would be finished being built we
do our final walk through last week of
September we were going to move in first
week of October which is why it was so
beautiful because we had that apartment
for a whole month so we can do a slow
move-in you know like yeah take our time
yeah
you know kind of like I'm gonna bring
one underwear at a time put like Hershey
syrup on her chest and just rub it like
we could really really like seduce
ourselves in this world yeah like tease
ourselves a little bit like oh I put I
brought in two socks and then just the
teasers would bring the two socks back
to the other yeah because we could
because we had the whole month right so
we're supposed to do that and then we
were supposed to uh they were supposed
to rap by uh November then biggest event
of the year for our company bottle
Brigade Black Friday we have all of
November to work on that then when that
happens uh end of November uh beginning
of December we get a puppy like there's
just we had like our the lap Q4
looked awesome yeah it was supposed to
be a like a chill out right because the
whole world celebrates together so
everything shuts down like business just
slows the [ __ ] down like we know it
everyone knows Q4 your slowest month of
the [ __ ] or the slowest few months of
the year yeah so don't even try like
just chill out and spend it with your
family so we were like let's [ __ ] get
it because this looks good yeah and we
were ending we're ending
um the year with adding a new furry
family member because that's something
we've been wanting so freaking bad but
because we've been moving and stuff like
that we couldn't you know yeah and so
that was what was
um on paper on the paper on the plans on
the clipboard coach is happy
go team break
boom we hit the quarter right and oh boy
so we hit the court leading up to the
end of September um I started getting
little red flags that we weren't going
to close on time because like usually
how like escrow works is through all the
escrows we've been in because we have so
many forever homes I know very
experienced how escrow works is it's
usually a three-week process
and usually all the due diligence all
the hard documents I need to talk to
your CPA give me your loans like how
many card payments do you have all that
because it's a lot of money so they want
to make sure that you're going to be
able to pay them back because they're
doing the due diligence as you're
talking about exactly they ask for all
those things usually
um up front in the first couple of days
even then the underwriters they have
time to really dig through the documents
and they have their own algorithm as to
uh can these owners afford what is going
on right and then questions pop up so
then you take like the last two weeks so
with us being entrepreneurs
um from what I understand regular WD to
people it's like I get it you're a nurse
you have one car payment or two boom
done done yeah it's straightforward the
next three weeks chilling for us it's
usually uh get financial documents first
week is like whoa I've never seen this
before you guys have how many companies
and then like almost like week two they
answer all the questions and like okay
cool a week I get it week three yeah
chilling yeah but it's not that
impossible and it's not that hard yeah
so it exactly this time
um you know they've because they've been
building our house for like eight months
now all those documents I already gave
them like way early on like back in
December the house is done at this point
yeah December of last year January I
gave it all to them right so they're
working on so for me I'm like oh all
that stuff's over yeah you're done you
did your part Paul's in their Court yeah
and you got my accountant CP uh CC did
uh what the [ __ ] am I saying cc'd on the
email yeah you got mine you could see
people you got my CPA cc'd on the
e-m-a-i-l and
um so when they started asking me
questions
like stuff that I'm used to seeing in
week one I'm like whoa whoa whoa
what do you mean and what week is this
at this point this is like a week or two
before okay whoo you know like what do
you mean you need my like 20 20 tax
returns that have already sent to you a
long time ago because what I understand
is if they if they need it that means
they need to still look through through
it you know of course so these things
are thick and I'm like what and then
they'll ask me for this what about this
or what about your credit cards or what
about this and they're like hey you know
what like
um
it's been like eight months so like more
of your car has gotten paid off and I'm
like no [ __ ]
[Music]
but what my monthly payments are right
I'm like I've never experienced this
level of like the Mastery the mastery
uh amateurity
um
idiot idiosity
[ __ ] getting Ridiculousness
I've never experienced any of this like
all of the things that like usually all
I guess everyone else we worked with are
Pros but just questions that I'm like
bro you're the expert why are you asking
me yeah it started coming up
and then the final straw audio was
already like oh [ __ ] I don't think we're
gonna close end of September but to me
I'm like hopeful probably just a week
later you know I mean these I've never
been in an escrow that doesn't close in
three weeks
ever ever ever ever nor have any of my
uh real estate friends ever heard of
that yep and in fact if you do cash buys
like people that just come out like uh
full on a paper cash for the house it's
like seven days right so never been
three weeks literally the day before
we're supposed to close I remember this
date vividly September 27th they still
asked me for like two or three of the
documents that are literally the core
things of what you need a base
affordability why are you trying to piss
me off all over again
that [ __ ] was so annoying and to top it
off while we're going through that right
we do our final walk through here which
is two days prior to that date that
you're talking about and this house is
all [ __ ] up yeah like you do a taping
tour of like any like imperfections or
or anything that was missed or anything
that's [ __ ] up like you just put tapes
on it so they can fix it before they
release this house to you I kid you not
there must have been like 400 pieces of
tape there's stuff that I was like bro
you telling me you can't see this yeah
like a cabinet where it's like crooked
or like nails are sticking out I'm like
bro like you don't even need me to come
and inspect you you need to inspect if I
was rude I'd be like bro you guys
inspect first and then let me know
because I don't even need to come in
this is this is like you was trying to
sell me a car with three tires yeah you
know like this is obvious yeah and then
um as as an owner to any type of
property you're about to close on you
want to do your due diligence and then
hire a inspector so we had our inspector
come in two days prior to our final
walk-through and he's just like um I
can't even inspect this because it's not
even done we're like what the [ __ ] is
happening fine so we walk into uh going
okay so are we going to close or what
with the loan people and then they're
like we're not gonna do it yeah so like
miraculously I don't know how they're
able to get the physical structure
completed like at the bare minimum like
yeah some hinges are off or whatever or
like some doors are squeaking like crazy
there's Nails coming through the carpet
but I guess it's enough to pass the home
off to us so cool the home is completed
we still have a one year warranty period
where they can come in and fix
everything yeah and they've been great
this whole point yeah we're like [ __ ]
that's cool yeah then they go hey it
doesn't look like it's going to close
tomorrow the lone people yes yes and
that's a [ __ ] nightmare especially
for someone like me who has to book
flights back and forth to Vegas and L.A
right because you're still filming JK
news at this point yeah I'm still
filming JK news and that's a good
three-day
um actually a four day because you leave
wanted to land to get their get settled
the next three days back to back to back
you're filming yeah there's that and um
I have to make time to come back to film
our podcast here and
um I also you know like we were trying
to end the year at the band with barbell
stuff so I still have flights going to a
bunch of like power lifting or Fitness
based events yep so it's not one of the
like if we agreed upon a date Us in the
escrow and the Builder of course we're
like okay three-way agree this date cool
because now I'm gonna build my life
around it absolutely when they move that
date I'm like bro do you know the damage
you have caused that's like they don't
there's a huge ripple effect right they
don't even give a [ __ ] so I know I'm
pissed all over again so they look hey
we're not gonna build the clothes and
I'm like mother
[ __ ] it's been eight months and you're
asking me for documents like until the
last draw I'm like what the [ __ ] I sent
it to you I sent it to your other
co-worker you have my CPAC seed like you
can ask him direct stop putting me in
this I don't even talk finances
and I was like so okay cool fine if we
have to because I'm a person that likes
to roll with the punches and as I prefer
to find a solution than to get angry
that's who I am
so I'm like all right give me another
date then because then I'll move
everything I'll have my other business
partners like I had other like meetings
people flying into town to meet and
stuff and I was like I'll just
restructure everything
and uh but I need a solid date and
they're like we can't even give you a
solid date and I'm like the [ __ ] does
that mean I'm like bro like I can go get
a haircut and they'll tell me we'll be
done probably 45 minutes
if something crazy happens I'll be done
in like an hour you know I'm like
everything has a literally lead time
yeah everything yeah every single thing
even the house yes I was like what do
you think is harder the the paperwork
you're doing or the house is being built
even the house they told us eight to 12
months and they met and they met it yeah
like it's [ __ ] up but it's done right
so I'm like what the [ __ ] bro
and so he gets pushed back week after
week after week after week so all of
September's gone all of end of September
is gone first half of October is gone
and then oh the big big crunch time
thing is so they base off our finances
off of like uh fiscal years oh yeah our
2020 2019 uh tax years our taxes on
2018. you know like for regular people
you file taxes in April for a lot of
businesses you file an extension and you
do the taxes in October because you have
so much more stuff to compile right
so now it's getting close to the October
15th date which is business tax season
because the problem why we don't want to
get there is all the finances that that
I've given them have been in
underwriting
if we go past October 15th now they're
going to require an additional year of
tax returns and what that means is all
that underwriting time is nullified and
they have to start all over again which
means we probably won't move until
[ __ ] January because everyone's out
the end of December so we're like the
whole time me my accountant our agent
we're like we need to [ __ ] contain
this [ __ ] someone needs to do
their job so we can finish this [ __ ] by
um October 15th performance yeah
and uh
they people working day and night people
started talk like texting at 11 p.m 9 00
P.M to get this thing going which is
like outside so I appreciate people
really pulling together I mean I don't
because I'm like you [ __ ] did this to
yourself true what the [ __ ] so um then
finally we got a closing date
right a closing date
um where we have to come in and sign and
we have to send out a check before was
like 2 p.m Eastern yeah because uh we
have to do it via wire because it's so
much money you can't unless yeah they're
not going to accept cash they're not
gonna accept cashiers checked they're
not gonna accept anything other than
like a wire transfer yeah because it's
verified funds from an institution sent
to another institution yeah and then
they since they're on the East Coast
they work off of East Coast time so yeah
or cut off out here is two because if
anything past that then it gets sent the
next day which is already late because
they can't fund anything yeah so the
date they gave us I believe it remember
was on the Vivid it was on a Monday and
they're like okay we're gonna sign this
day on a Monday right maybe it was like
the 17th or something something like
that but it was a Monday yeah uh it was
a Monday and I remember because
um
out of all the craziness that we have
going on even with JK we have to balance
people's schedules and people are
starting to get more bookings so I'm
really happy for them but our usual
filming goes from Thursday Friday
Saturday we have to move it to Monday
Tuesday and Wednesday so now I gotta
text all the JK crew yo my [ __ ] bad
but um the signing that I have to do
it's on a Monday so what I was gonna do
was
um actually like fly back from
I was already gonna be in La I think
shooting barbell stuff yeah I was going
to fly you did fly in you flew in so you
were already in LA to shoot barbell
stuff you flew in because it gave you
that date and um we said we could not uh
We're not gonna go past 11 o'clock by 11
o'clock we should be wrapped yeah and
then I'll fly right back out and get the
second half of JK news because it's two
halves so then it was gonna work out
perfectly it is hectic for you
unfortunately but you were going to be
able to like meet all your to-do's yeah
so I was gonna get a sub for the morning
session and I was like cool I booked my
flights that's uh what got locked in
and
um and the day before we got the
approval letter like yes you guys got it
we met it and we were like oh was it
Friday on Friday they were like yes
everything's been approved the loan is
approved we're good to go and literally
30 minutes later you get another email
going actually we need to fit why why
has your credit card not paid been paid
off or some [ __ ] like that like we had
like 2 000 like they showed that we owe
two thousand dollars on a credit card
yeah the email like email what the [ __ ]
the approval email even had a [ __ ]
ribbon in it yeah congrats the loans
approved so we're like okay cool we're
like all the crazy hectic 11 p.m text
back and forth call like getting the
whole team on board to close this
goddamn escrow we thought it was good
and then 30 minutes right after hey
there's still a credit card not and I'm
like what [ __ ] credit card I'm like I
pay off all my [ __ ] credit cards all
the yeah we had zero and it was like
this one says 30 bucks or something and
I was like you're gonna hold up a
million dollar transaction for 30 bucks
I was like so I looked back I was like
what is it what are they talking about
and I looked and it's the same thirty
dollars on every single month it's a
utilities payment it is it's a phone
yeah so I texted him I'm like I mean I
email them I'm like dude you guys as
Underwriters do you even read the
financial documents because if you do
you can tell this is utilities so
depending on what time of the month you
look at this credit card there will be a
a debit or there won't be a debit
depending on their building cycle so
it's not I haven't paid it off I'm gonna
get this every single month because I
pay this [ __ ] on this autopay I'm like
are you guys first time [ __ ]
Financial people or what yeah anyways
[ __ ] pissed off right
this is when the second enchilada comes
the [ __ ] second tidal wave yes that
is Saturday yes so Friday I'm [ __ ]
dealing with this [ __ ] I was like Yay
whoopee [ __ ] what kind of because we
were like okay we're kind of gonna make
yeah yeah double double high fives we
think we got it then we got the [ __ ]
[ __ ] email that night we're like oh
my God okay so it looks like
um Monday even though the the flights
are booked it's still a [ __ ] crap
shoot because literally 30 minutes after
the ribbon email it's oh my God I still
need these things I don't know what the
hell is going on so I'm like well the
fights books I'm [ __ ] coming no
matter what next day
Saturday is when
the biggest tidal wave of my life
happens
um we were I've been packing getting
ready sorting stuff out it was just a
regular beautiful Saturday beautiful
Saturday evening yeah
um
I I remember I went to go take a nap
because I was in the room by myself yeah
and let's go take a nap I was extremely
tired
and then I get a text from my mom
and um to catch you guys up
long story short because there's a lot
of Vlogs that don't cover a lot of this
stuff this is a big window of
like a story that happened is my dad
moved in with us because of geosmart
idea my dad wanted to live closer to us
to be in Vegas
and um
to make sure that the Market's time out
Jill was like instead of
buying
the the house in Vegas and the waiting
for it to be built and then your dad
sell his house which would be around
this time and we've seen the government
hike the interest rates a bunch of times
like your dad's not going to get the
most for his house so what would be
smart is if he sold his house at Peak
market right now and I think what was it
maybe even like March or April when he
sold it yeah it was it was the hottest
time or even before then yeah but
whatever peak time was he was like she
was like sell it now
have them move in with us he's been
wanting to live with us for a long time
and it would be cool for taika and my
dad it's a win-win everyone like during
covid they weren't really hanging out as
much you know so like this would be
really cool and I'm like I was like bro
I was like that's dope so my dad moved
in which is why you guys see me training
him he's in our Vlogs we go eat together
my lap my dad lost uh 30 pounds it was
[ __ ] yeah he was killing it like a
Chinese Santa Claus and he went down to
like Chinese David Beckham
oh God yeah and um
yeah and that so that was all cool
and then towards like I think a few
months in um maybe three four months
three four months in living with us my
dad I think started to see that like yo
I don't think living here is
um how I imagined because he'll be like
telling me things like man I went to the
DMV and no one spoke Chinese went to the
hospital to get my new hearing aids no
one spoke Chinese I'm like yeah dude I'm
like the the 626 San Gabriel Valley
there's literally only like one or two
places in all of America that's like
that like you go down Garvey Avenue Bank
of America is in Chinese that's how
densely populated uh Chinese people are
over there Las Vegas is extremely
diverse but you're not going to have
like extreme catering that way so I just
think his regular daily life
um
what is it called like felt very
inconvenienced
and so uh randomly out of the blue my
dad pitches an idea to me he goes I want
to talk to you and I'm like sure what is
it he goes you know uh I
am alone
your mom is alone we're divorced we only
have you
what if I go and talk to Mom
and I was like talk to Mom about what
yeah I was like
um like rekindle and he goes yeah whoa
and I'm like okay
um Mom literally like texts me like
every week
I can tell you right now that
you have not been on her mind for 30
years you know I'm like most of the
stuff that's on my mom's mind is either
Buddhism or her parents like that's all
she really cares about and then me
and um he's like no but I want I really
want to try you know we're both old we
can like kind of lean on each other uh
like whatever needs that she wants I
could be there for her I'm like I guess
I guess so so I remember that and then
who are you to prevent him from what he
wants to do exactly so adult so for me
me basing my life math like how I'm able
to like have court vision and see what's
going on to me I was like 90 is gonna be
a failure so the night before uh I
remember the night before supposed to
leave our current house to go into our
short-term rental yeah yeah I told my
dad I was like Hey Dad I've been
thinking about what you told me and
these are my final thoughts
I was like
do I think
um you want to go talk to mom is crazy
yes
and I was like do I think it's going to
be successful I'm like based off all the
people that I've dealt with in the last
10 years of business I've rubbed
shoulders with all kinds of walks of
life and I think I understand people
pretty well now
I don't even think you and Mom should
have gotten married to begin with
because your personalities are so
different like you guys are not
compatible I understand during those
times you probably have societal
pressures both of you guys are aging you
have to get married have to have a kid
so I get that so I don't put any blame
on you but to be honest I don't think I
should have been born
so I don't think the success rate is
high take it back
why yeah
and then so I and so I told him I was
like but and here's a huge butt
everyone I've ever told that I wanted to
do JK
told me I was gonna fail too
so I understand where you're coming from
if you have big dreams I was like as
your son I support whatever dream you
want that's so cute yeah I got your back
but in terms of like reality I want you
to have good expectations I don't want
it to fail and then you go oh my God I
can't believe it didn't work I'm like
you should go into it knowing it's not
gonna work but you're gonna believe in
your heart and whatever happens gonna
happen
and he goes okay I appreciate that I was
like because that's how I felt with JK
like the world was against me even you
and Mom but I still did it and look look
where we are today you know so I was
like so I I support you and if you need
anything let me know
so the next day when we moved into our
apartment apartment or short-term rental
that's when we part of ways my dad's
like okay
um I'm gonna go over to your mom's so
he's been at my mom's
um at this point now maybe a month and a
half almost two yeah but day one
um they started fighting obviously my
dad will text me hey your mom said this
to me and my mom will text me hey your
dad said this to me I'm like
I already [ __ ] knew this was gonna
happen but I was like [ __ ] it you know
they're all just
whatever right
so long story short they've been living
together for two months not as lovers
more as cohabitants
um my mom is a very like strict and by
the books one step at a type type of
person
to the point where even when my dad was
going to come in she was like okay if
you're gonna come in I'm accepting you
as my son's father
not as lovers so don't try any of that
freaky [ __ ] and uh we're gonna set up a
Rules of Engagement so if it doesn't go
well your ass is gone and we'll even get
this [ __ ] notarized that's how by the
books my mom is she doesn't like to [ __ ]
around I love it just like to [ __ ]
around you know yeah so at least she's
like I'm gonna control all variables
we're both on the same goddamn page do
you agree to these terms and conditions
before we enter it you know before like
they have a good time and then one thing
leads to another and they're [ __ ] you
have another brother yeah we have
another brother and then they're like
what the [ __ ] you know and they get
divorced a second time or some other
[ __ ]
my mom I just want to rule all that out
two months in they're living I know
they're um
um
having fights not the smoothest but also
didn't seem like it was it's not
abnormal the worst yeah
so going back to that Saturday where I
woke up from a nap I get a text from my
mom
that says
your dad killed himself
and I was like
what the [ __ ] does that mean is this
um my mom uses Google translate
sometimes but sometimes she texts me in
Chinese or does she exaggerate you know
because when you don't have a Mastery of
the language
you sometimes there's things Lost in
Translation for sure I was like
what is she talking about so I I called
her immediately yeah I'm like my mom
like what do you mean dad killed himself
like I was like did you have a
stomachache or did he like eat a hot
pepper or some [ __ ] like that you know
like what what is it like did he do
something that would seem like he was
gonna kill him somebody he killed
himself
um and then
she she picks up she goes your dad
killed himself there's police and over
at my house right now
I have it settled
um I just needed to let you know
and then I was like
okay
and then we hung up
and no [ __ ] I probably just stared
at the wall for five minutes
of course I didn't know like you know I
was taking a nap too I was like of
course surreal what the [ __ ] is this
like what the hell's going on
I don't even know how to process it
uh I definitely don't know how to tell
you
because that's something you never hear
anyone saying right like you're even if
someone passes away you don't even know
how to say like this person is no longer
alive like how do you report that yeah
so I was like
what the [ __ ]
so I got up I went to go see you and I'm
like remember I was like hey babe I need
to tell you something and I was like can
you please just stay in the living room
because I know how strong it is like I
was like okay okay usually he's like
[ __ ] wrong he's like okay and he sits
down
and I remember I told you I was like my
dad committed suicide and then you're
like what I'm like yeah and then you're
like you need to go yeah you were like I
don't know what to do yeah yeah you know
I was like what the [ __ ]
um so you're like you need to go right
now yeah you need to go to your mom's
yes I pack my bags jumped in the car uh
so from Vegas I started um plowing my
way down to La as I was driving
I was like
oh [ __ ] is this one of those Antics that
my mom does I can't even believe your
brain goes there because that's [ __ ]
that they've done yeah I mean like I
mean you've heard the story of my mom's
stealing her own car before yes I have
and checking the gas and the mileage
yeah so like my mom does [ __ ] crazy
antics
um so I was just like wait is this one
of those things where my mom and my dad
devised the plan of like yo I wonder if
our son would like come to our need at
the drop of a dime
like let's we should test them you know
so I was like [ __ ] this better not be
that you know because I was like as you
know I have to still [ __ ] fly back
and forth and sign papers and do some I
yeah yeah there's something on the line
right now it's huge that's been [ __ ]
on that's been like burdening me for a
while that I can't wait to fix and be on
with it and
um oh that [ __ ] this better not be
[ __ ] it I'm driving
about 45 minutes and I get a phone call
I mean at this point I'm ready for
anything I usually don't pick up any
numbers I don't recognize but I was like
at this point with that kind of news I
was like I have to be ready
it was like some sort of three two three
number so it's La pick up the phone and
they're like hi this is detective yada
yada
um I just want to let you know that your
father has passed and explain everything
that my mom explained to me
um that she explained to me in Chinese
but now in English police formalities
and I was like
almost like the second
um
round of chills went through
and I'm like [ __ ] this isn't
fake you know this isn't a test or
whatever
tells it okay thank you
um they're like I'm so sorry for your
loss all that stuff I'm like cool
I drive
go back to
um
Ellie go back to LA
and I arrive at my mom's house
and even when I arrived there like it
just it freaks me out because I see my
dad's car but I know what has happened
you know so just a lot of like you know
when like when you see things visually
it hits you harder yeah in my mind it's
like I know that this has happened yeah
right now I'm seeing [ __ ] you know and
then um I go in
and I uh I see my mom and my mom looks
[ __ ] up like she's been crying or like
just literally witnessed the worst thing
in the world
um I just give her a hug I'm like I'm
here anything you need
you're okay and she's like thank you so
much
and um
I go inside I look in the room that my
dad was staying in you see all his stuff
but it's empty
and um
it just feels like
so eerie
because at that moment I'm still
processing stuff
and it was like I had to like leave my
wife and kid who I already don't see as
much because I fly back and forth so
much
and then I'm dealing with the house
thing
and then now my dad passes so it almost
seems like nothing in this world really
matters besides family so I don't give a
[ __ ] about anything
but at the same time it also does
matters because
um like your house and your finances and
livelihood dictates how you spend the
rest of your life
so it was just like
pulled in a billion directions but I was
there for my mom so that's all I cared
about
and so um that night
um I know like my mom's very spiritual
so she'll get scared and stuff like that
um especially since my dad committed
suicide in her house
so I slept next to my mom
um
in the bed
and just trying to like we're just
talking and like try to like
make sense of anything help her yeah
yeah because it's just questions you
know there's no no note no last text
message
no no nothing no like Manifesto yeah and
then the way your dad has always
operated ever since I've entered the
picture he's a very put together person
like he thinks five ten years ahead
um and he's always just has everything
prepared so that no one ever has to deal
with any of his [ __ ] like um he already
had his like what is it his Tombstone or
whatever since like 20 freaking no not
20 like 1998 or something like that yeah
like he's had it forever because he goes
well this is your dad's just a very
logical person yeah it's very logical
and he's very like
anticipatory I should say like like he
went to Kirkland and he bought our
Costco he bought eight pairs of Kirkland
shoes and he calculated these are the
amount of shoes I need for the rest of
my life even with like the property
um the the new property in Vegas that he
was gonna stay at he was like I know
this is how much you know utilities
should cost like I already have my lump
sum of of money just so that like he
just did all the calculations already
like he just knows exactly the routine
of Life he's going to be living and he
just calculated all of that and he goes
hey I know I'm also going to get old so
here's this amount of money so that you
know I can cover hospital bills or
whatever and I'm like who thinks that
way yeah he even thinks like after this
car
um I'm probably gonna Outlast this car I
probably still need one more car so he
has money saved for another car because
I'm probably gonna drive one more car
before I die yeah so I think because of
all of that planning it was also hard
to pick up on any type of of signals of
of Christ for help or anything yeah
because also in all of that planning all
of that planning ends at like 80 90. you
know like he took his life at like 70
something that was so abrupt because all
the planning we've ever talked about the
last decade or two has been okay like
this how many shoes I need to wear until
I'm like 85. um I'll probably drive a
car until I'm 90 years old or I'm 90
then if I really need help can you put
me in an old person's home like
everything is that far ahead of Planet
you know and he's like 70 something
right now
or was 70 something
um
so yeah so I'm just like so you're there
over the weekend we're still in Vegas
trying to console my mom still dealing
with the luckily it had I guess the
lucky thing is that the loan people
can't really say [ __ ] over the weekend
or are you still talking to them via
texting we are because they're like you
know they're over they're working around
the clock to make that date work yeah
because I don't think they want it to be
dragged on that long either yeah they
probably hate us yeah and I'm sure their
managers hate them they're like what the
[ __ ] you guys had like eight months to
do it and you guys are still working on
this show I hope so you should be on to
the next project you know so I think
everyone just hates it all around
so yeah dealing with my mom
um you know I'm not very like Buddhist
or anything but
any type of Buddhist
ritual I'm just there to support her
um because I think my mom has a very
like and rightfully so but a very why me
uh mindset for that moment a hundred
percent she should because from her
perspective it's like okay I have a very
peaceful life right now I'll have to do
is worry about myself I get to do my
Buddhist thing I get to see my son
whenever he comes into town or if I want
to go see him she has full Freedom she
has Financial Freedom freedom of time
freedom of travel she's a hundred
percent free yeah she's financially set
like we give her a monthly allowance
and she has a rental property like so
Finance multiple yeah Finance retirement
allowance all that said like she's like
living her best life and then so for my
dad to randomly approach her
she didn't have to and she was like well
fine like you're my you are the person I
created life with
fine like let's let's try this out for
the sake of that and then now you commit
suicide in my house like what the [ __ ]
so um her whole world is rocking up
she's like do I keep this place like
everything I plan for
is all wrecked at this moment now her
house is Tainted as weird feelings and
of spicy for Spiritual all you can think
about is like ghosts of people
especially because of the way your dad
passed right like it's it's not like a
he passed in his sleep because that's
some a different type of energy to deal
with you know but it's like when you're
taking your own life that's that's a
huge energy of like sadness and
loneliness and just this heavy heavy
Darkness you know so I think even if he
had passed naturally I I feel like your
mom would have had it just she would
just have a different feeling yeah she's
like oh that's that's what life is yeah
like she might even feel enlightened a
bit to be like whoa like I was you know
maybe I helped or facilitated some sort
of Peace yeah but this is like
self-sabotage yeah
and so it also makes like everything
every single conversation my mom and my
dad have in the morning that much more
eerie now because now everything uh
lends itself to double meaning yeah like
for example
um my in the morning like my mom had to
go get her car picked up from the the
shop in the morning day of day of in the
morning and then my mom was like Hey
like oh by the way I was supposed to I
was actually supposed to go to LA to
even grab dinner with my mom and my dad
the day after on Sunday actually
so because of that um
my mom and I was like oh I'm gonna go
buy food so we'll have a bunch of food
at home because my mom eats vegetarian
food and she knows I have a favorite
vegetarian spot so she was gonna go buy
vegetarian food so that we can all eat
vegetarian food Sunday the next day
and then my mom told my dad I'm gonna go
get it and then my dad's like
um no you go I'll be here waiting for
you
and so like under normal circumstances
you just hear like okay cool of course
yeah like now when you hear [ __ ] like
that when you think back to it you're
like
was he pleased she was the first person
to find him yeah like was is this was
she planning or was he planning it what
is that supposed to mean so there's so
many like uh trade-off and conversation
that have double meaning now and so my
mom of course is like what the [ __ ] like
why didn't you tell me you could have
told me you could ask for help or
anything like that
so yeah obviously uh no help and even
for me coming down I was like
um I'm we were gonna eat tomorrow
why did you do it today like you knew
you knew it's been in our College we've
been talking we're gonna have like our
first mom
dad son dinner and um that's what he's
wanted for years yeah and then we're
gonna like work it out like why did you
do it today when this was gonna happen
tomorrow so even I have questions you
know or [ __ ] ton of questions
but I think for me I was there more for
my mom so I was just trying to like you
know help ease her and all that stuff
and then obviously after that it's my
due diligence not because I'm next of
kin so I have to
tell the people he's closest with which
is his older sister
his brother
those are the two main people that he's
close with
and my dad is like you said very logical
person so even me going through his
phone most of the people I don't even
recognize because I think he technically
only have strangers numbers anyone that
he really needs to know is in here
so
um yeah I actually had to like look
around to find like the his brother and
sister's numbers and I felt bad for you
because
just the whole situation right like how
excuse me like how do you explain
um a couple that's been divorced for 30
years right and then now they they're
cohabitating for a couple months and
then he passes it's like I I was just
really scared that they were going to
start putting any type of blame or
hatred you know through you towards your
mom you know and I'm just like how is
someone gonna take that I just didn't
know what the relationships were going
to be or were like that I just I really
I really ached for you because you're
just this like innocent bystander you
know like you're just the most innocent
person in this entire
storyline then I'm like [ __ ] how are you
you know and I think you were just
you're I guess lucky for me and you
you're super logical that you were able
to sort through [ __ ] rather quickly you
know but I was just like I just felt
like you were carrying a lot of the
weight because it's like there was just
so many different sides that you were
trying to like uphold
yeah for me
um obviously I'm very like sad because
he's my dad I lost my pops so regardless
of how that happens I'll be sad
the other side is
um I'm a firm believer that we are only
our choices right whether you're rich or
whether you're poor or whatever your
background where you come from Walk of
Life you come from
um you are your character and your
character is determined by your choices
so if that's how he wanted to go
um
if that's how you wanted to go then
that's what he wanted to do yeah
and I just have to be I guess the best
son that I can be yeah and kind of like
deal with the aftermath and sort all
that stuff out right you know so while
all of that is happening
um
you you're still talking to the loan
people Sunday rolls around
they give us the day hey Monday we're
going to close for sure maybe they said
remember uh no they said for sure and
and we were like our realtor got really
um like uh she got really on top of it
and was like okay when's the absolute
latest that we can sign so she got that
time she was okay what's the earliest
that you guys can take a signing and
that's when they were like 11. yeah so
by 11 we should have everything in our
office so that's like we were like [ __ ]
it we're gonna be there at like 10 30
sitting at the parking lot yeah so um
after spending two days with my mom
flew right back in to Vegas to fix all
that as we're sitting there that's when
more [ __ ] started to unfold to seem like
it wasn't gonna happen yeah because 11
rolled around no papers to sign and then
because they said that was 11 and then
like 11 30 12.
12 30 12 30. 1 30. and then we're on the
phone constantly they're like no we
don't have update it's an underwriting
and I it almost seems like up
underwriting is like the secret room of
people that no one could talk to I'm
like well what do the underwriters say
how long do they think they need no
answer right
and it wasn't until what like oh and
then they said okay the final final
final Final time you have to wire the
money because this is what they're even
saying they're like you know what here's
here's another strategy what we can do
is this is the money that you need for
the down payment of the house wire over
so at least they receive it and then if
you paid technically you you did pay and
then now it'll close escrow and if
there's anything over they'll send it
back to you do that and it's okay cool
tell us what is the bulk amount and they
won't even do that but we just been
harping on that two o'clock we have to
send some money over and then boom I
remember two watch out
[ __ ] damn
it didn't register
did I tell you guys a rough month or
what
don't worry my head's all right
you're like don't worry I wasn't yeah
so yeah
um
two o'clock rolls around
and we're like
it's almost like you know that part of
the movie yeah we're waiting for like
Batman to come
and then
goes over and we're like
[ __ ]
not only did my pops just passed away
but I guess we lost our house or we're
not moving in for
a few more months
and
um the rest of the year how we had it
planned is completely [ __ ]
and um then what happened I remember so
it was two o'clock but we know like the
ladies at the office for us to do the
final closing the signing and all that
she was the only one giving us updates
at that point because I think everyone
was just shooting bricks that we had
been talking to the entire time and we
were just barking at them at this point
like our realtor was barking at them
probably their manager was barking at
them I was barking at them you were
barking so a bunch of [ __ ] barking
was happening that they were probably
going so they were not giving us any
updates the ladies in the uh the office
were coming out every you know every
update that they got just to let you
know this is happening this is happening
so even though it was past two o'clock
we were still getting hope with every
time she came out you know so so she
just kept saying like wait a minute it
looks like it might you know I don't
want it you know put your hopes up
because anything can happen at this
point but we're still pushing it forward
so we were like all right [ __ ] it
um we just sat there and it wasn't until
like five o'clock
that the wire made it miraculously she's
like I have never seen this in the
history of time the wire made it
um our loan got funded because we ended
up sending it at 2 or 215 or what was it
um we didn't even need to send it
we didn't even need to do any of that
stuff we did it I don't think so [ __ ] I
forgot same but
or maybe we did and it actually went
through or some [ __ ] I can't remember
but no we have to send the wire fine
then the wire made it um and it got
funded that same day which she was also
like I can't even believe this is
happening she goes that's it oh that's
the thing because you have to send a
wire before two four to get funded the
same day any wire sent after it gets
funded the next day but if it gets
funded the next day then that's fine you
have to open a hot another year of tax
returns and then I think for us
something came in at like 250 and like
okay send the wire boom we sent the wire
and she's like we'll see what happens in
the I don't know 20 years I've been
doing this yeah it has never been fun to
the same day yeah but boom Hallelujah
[ __ ] crazy miracle happened it did
get funded it got funded and we were
there till five o'clock and it was so
anti-climactic like our realtor was
there bless her soul the entire time and
we were just starving and frustrated oh
and I had to delay my flight three times
three times that's supposed to come back
at like a certain time I think like one
or something to shoot yeah the JK
careful boys were calling you like hey
are you just messing with us
I don't want to ruin the Vibes for them
because I know like you know JK is all
about having a fun time they're filming
I don't want to like crush them with
some crazy ass news yeah so I just kept
delaying the flight oh no no no I'm not
it's not a prank I'm just dealing with a
lot right now and then um
uh finally I was able to fly back in
yeah at night which after I you left
that same day yeah I pushed the flight
uh like to like seven or something like
that oh right because I know I have to
film the next day still um my because I
couldn't make it on Monday and not the
film on the next day yeah um because
they were like they were like you can
get your keys now and we were like okay
everything's been [ __ ] everything
about this house building process has
been [ __ ] and I understand that right
now the work force is super slim and the
shortages everywhere and there's supply
chain issues and so it's causing a lot
of like hiccups in every single industry
I understand it so as soon as she says
you're free to get your keys I'm like I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm gonna go right now
and get my [ __ ] house keys to know
that it's my house and no one else's
house and and then so I came to pick up
my my keys and as I was getting my keys
you were headed to the airport yeah so I
was heading to the airport so I didn't I
didn't even get the keys I was like
mama's gonna get the keys
I didn't do the opening it together
going we're home nothing that's why it
wasn't anti-climactic but I was like at
this point I don't I can't
um afford the uh the luxuries of things
I just got to get [ __ ] done flew back
did the next two days of JK news
um we had some tough ones some suicide
based news some Death News and I just
had to swallow it and try to be as
professional as I can and not let it
spill into the workplace
and then afterwards I broke the news to
all the dudes and you know everyone was
super comforting and they're like yo let
me know if you need anything now that I
think about it when we moved I should
have probably asked him for help because
they did say they were going to help me
yeah they've we [ __ ] up but we ended
up moving on our own
[Laughter]
um but yeah like everyone was you know
super super
um understanding supportive and and
everyone was so kind and you know people
were constantly checking in on you and
um um people like I think even Mike came
down like it was just it was a beautiful
thing to see your group come together
for you like that yeah
so because of that
um and from that point until now we're
slightly back on track now like our
house is still in boxes and shambles
because we moved way past the time that
we're supposed to oh by the way we have
all these vendors and stuff that have to
keep postponing like like mirror people
the gym assembly and everyone they need
to do their job so they'll hit me up
they're like yo when can I bring in the
mirror I have to bring in the mirror and
they charge you know one of them was my
oh you know what one of the Mayors broke
at the warehouse so it's just like when
my [ __ ] is [ __ ] I have to give that
info to other people yeah and then so
I'm feeling pressure from both sides the
gym assembly people hey if you if you
can't do this date the next time is like
two weeks down the line so I'm like
managing and juggling all of this
um while my Pops passed
so just dealing with a lot
um but we're
slightly a little bit on track now
um
until we heard about taika school
yeah so as you guys know Tech has been
dealing with
um a lot of uh like seizure issues we're
trying to see what the hell is going on
you know he's currently taking
medication while the medication you know
is is
we don't know what the medication's
doing because even though he's on the
highest dosage of this medication he's
still getting his seizures he's still
got one yeah yeah he's still got one the
most recent one being Halloween morning
what seemed to me to be literally out of
nowhere
um
so because of this medication that he's
been taking now for about like four or
five months now you know there are side
effects to every single medication that
you ever take yeah sometimes cause
drowsiness drowsiness some of them may
you know they tell you don't operate any
big machinery on because every single
medication you take will have a side
effect
um unfortunately for taika's medication
has you know the side effects are
aggression irritability
um extreme mood swings yeah mood swings
and I'm fortunate to impulse control
yeah to taika
um he's only five like you know we
understand as adults when something's
off and we're like oh [ __ ] something's
off kilter here like yeah I need to get
off this [ __ ] it's making me think
either suicidal thoughts or it's making
me you know feel no emotion like we can
gauge what's what's abnormal yeah if
you're an adult and like let's say you
smoke weed you have the self-awareness
and go oh I'm high yeah yeah yeah kids
are just high and they're just doing
things but then when the repercussions
come they go wait what happened yeah so
that's unfortunately what's been
happening at
at school is he the irritability is
coming in the aggression the mood swings
and and I feel for him so hard because
he doesn't even know that he's doing it
to the point now
where I would just last night I was
reading him a book about kindness
um because you know we're still trying
to be parents and and steer him in the
right direction and teachers are trying
to be teachers and teach and steer and
Coach so everyone is kind of coming down
not hard but everyone is just coming
down on taika a lot about the same thing
like hey don't push people why are you
crying all of a sudden like hey don't
have a tantrum like and yeah these do
sound like
actual kid behaviors but I think the
frequency and and the intensity that
he's he's experiencing all these things
are just not normal
um so because of that his school now
just I mean we're still dealing with
this at the moment but his school's like
hey I don't because it's a little
private school they don't have very many
resources but they're also like hey
um we don't think that this is a good
school for taika anymore and we're like
wait are you kicking them out and
they're like well no we we're not
kicking him out but you know we also
feel guilty taking your guys's tuition
money
um when we know that we like we just
feel he's so stressed here but to me
that's we're not kicking them out but
we're kicking them out basically yeah
you know
um thank you we're not kicking them out
on the traditional like either he's
failing or like he got into a ton of
fights like yeah none of the traditional
ones yeah it's just more like this guy
is and does not fit his place yeah so
um yeah that's been the new kind of
thing that we've been dealing with
um in addition to everything else that's
kind of been going on
so yeah now we gotta like explore either
homeschooling or but one thing for sure
is I'm taking that kid off medication
yeah or finding another school yeah find
just yeah finding a different learning
environment regardless of what the
ingredients are but one of the main ones
we're taking out is the medicine because
we want the old Tiger back because
um it sucks when you're like
when you have to take a medication and
it brings a side out of you
and then so people are responding to
this side
but that's not even who you are but then
but the self-esteem it hits doesn't hit
the medicine self-esteem it hits your
real self-esteem like every single time
he gets in trouble like oh like why did
you just run over there why just blurt
this out why did you just push a kid
um
like he's doing it from the medicine
because he has no impulse control I mean
he's also a kid right yeah and then but
when the teacher or parent is chastising
you
you're taking that in in real life
so now like we can see like him going
like almost lose a little bit of
confidence uh down on himself like he
can't do anything right and that's the
last thing we want when building up when
we want to build a bright confident
little dude you know
yeah
so yeah that's uh
that's what we've been that's what's
been going on the last couple of months
I was trying to tell like I was trying
to tell you right like I always try to
look for the lesson in every situation I
always try to stay positive and I'm
always like
I think we've been overdue
you know where I'm like overdue on what
like challenges like this like we've had
a pretty easy life yeah or like
something awesome so I'm like okay [ __ ]
it it's our time to get challenged bring
it on you know yeah and I was saying
this in a vlog too and I'm like [ __ ] it
life tries to throw a wrench in your
system [ __ ] bring it on I'm like but
not too hard like take it easy
I'm thinking about like what are some
lessons I learned
um
I think some of the lessons I learned is
uh
family is important you know
in uh
I think like
when something bad happens
like your family like with my dad your
family like whatever you need you know
my friends or like whatever you need
um
and taking care of our family
is like the most important
and also like no matter what plan or how
think to the books your plan is
Anything Can Happen instantly so be
flexible
and um I mean all of this stuff that
we've been going through Titan knows
nothing about it doesn't know anything
about escrow or right now he thinks
Grandpa's on vacation because we don't
even know how to break it to him just
you know how do you yeah you know
um it's easier if it was like he passed
away I mean that's normal we can say
that but when you say the other one
you're like yeah we probably won't what
does that mean you know for a long time
that's not that's a rated R it's not
even age appropriate yeah
so
um yeah but I'm really grateful to have
you as my partner in my life
and as much
um
stuff as taiku has been going through to
me he's still the cuniest guy in the
whole universe
and I love snuggling with them every
single morning seeing him in his pajamas
and his tight pajamas
and uh
those two are like the most important
things in my life
everything else profession where we live
how we live all that stuff can change
as long as we all have each other
and I think that's the most important
thing
it's big CUNY
I don't even know if I could talk right
now I'm all choked up and [ __ ]
what's in a you don't think it's weird
that you're choked up and your titties
about to pop out is it
I mean I would like it too oh
what's an important lesson I've learned
through this
obviously the family one it's really
cool to see who has your back with
nothing to gain so that's been really
dope
um like seeing my family just kind of
band together for your family's been
really cool
um
honestly right now I think because it's
on the surface and just in the Forefront
of our mind is
um we have to 100 dictate what we want
for taika you know I think at the
beginning I was like well doctors are
doctors they know what they're doing you
know but every doctor is different every
doctor has
um their specialty
um you know the amount of of information
that they keep up with and there are
city doctors as well as good doctors
yeah every profession I think he's
current neurologist I think is an
absolute piece of [ __ ] so I'm like I'm
I'm 100 gonna get him off medication and
heal him through like food and stuff
speaking of the monster hey mister
the snacks are coming dude we'll get you
a little snacky snack
kind of perfect timing because we were
just talking about e-monkey
okay I'll call you we're almost done in
five minutes
oh I gotta see what happened yeah
yeah they'll be coming
but
okay
but yeah that was that was my lesson of
just taking control of everything and
um just knowing that you need to do your
research you need to know what you want
and
um I've even had other moms in my circle
that are like
doctors have called her like a bad
mother and she was like I'm trusting my
gut I'm gonna go with it and she was
able to heal
like hurt kid with it you know yeah so
yeah that's that's been one of the
biggest lessons I've currently learned
I'm glad we're able to
catch people finally yeah because people
have been wondering where the podcasts
have been and our Vlogs and just it's
been
the wildest couple of months like I've
never dealt with anything this crazy
even when my dad passed you know because
I feel like
those are things that I still are still
within my control even though it was
unexpected and it's just one of the
first real big deaths I've had in my
family yeah that I was like okay fine
like I it just it was a beginning and an
end like I understood it and I can move
on but this one is just one thing on top
of the other on top of the other on top
of the other and it's literally things I
can't control and I'm not even a control
freak by any means but I'm just saying
like
um if I knew that I had a hand in the
negative outcome then um I'm not going
to be sad because I'm gonna be like duh
it's my fault but with all of these
things that have happened I'm like we've
done our best we did our job and and
and it's turning out in a different way
and I think that's the part where it's
like holy [ __ ] it's been hard it has
been
but we're here for sure and I'm grateful
but God damn yeah we could use a break
it'd be nice to have a break I mean
tomorrow we're getting a little
loud because taika's right next door
good dog so that's gonna be really dope
yeah watch it like destroy everything
like it bites through the wires and [ __ ]
we're like [ __ ] I can't imagine that
happening dogs are perfect
yeah anything else you want to say no
I'm really happy we're able to share
this moment and really check in with
each other a little bit more
it's been rough yeah
but I love you I love you okay I don't
care anymore you end it you you do you
do it well that's it thank you guys for
uh sticking around like always
and we try to keep it real as 100 as we
can
um sorry we've been a little bit absent
here and there we've been trying to keep
all of the things we have going on
afloat as much as possible
and that's kind of like one of the the
cons of spreading yourself too thin
where if something drastic like this
happens
um some of the things that you're doing
ends up falling down but I think we're
on track to putting stuff back in place
and we'll be stronger than ever next
year hell yeah